alexis vous pouvez un bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions comment est-ce
que vous interprétez la sortie d'olivier
verrons quel bilan sous le coup de cette
conférence de presse ou bien on sent
bien le feuilleton nage par rapport à l'
annonce du confinement en disant il ne
faut surtout pas brusquer les français
vu qu'ils sont moins d'un sur deux ou
quasiment un sur deux à ne plus vouloir
de mode tolérer ces confinement donc il
va falloir amener des preuves sur le
pourquoi de ce confinement donc on
attend les chiffres on attend de voir où
on va et c'est clairement là dans cette
conférence de presse olivier ferrand ne
se mouille pas ils nous baladent en
rappelant un les vaccins la campagne de
vaccination qui est en cours qu'il n'y
aura pas de délai entre les deux
injections de deux doses et cetera
mais sur la stratégie épidémique dans
l'épidémie évidemment il fait allusion
aux variants anglais et aux autres
variantes du corona virus éviter
l'épidémie dans l'épidémie c'est quoi
c'est préparer les esprits c'est ça
c'est ce que vous dites oui tout à fait
c'est de dire que aujourd'hui le couvre
feu de 18h ne suffit pas ce qu'il dit
c'est que ça évite d'être sous une vague
et qu'on est sur un plateau épidémique
mais avec ces variants les infections
pourraient repartir à la hausse
donc si le couvre-feu ne suffit pas
qu'est ce qui est après ça eh bien c'est
le confinement alors les scènes les
scénarios puisqu'on a beaucoup de
scénaristes autant conseil de défense à
l'elysée et et rue de ségur vont parler
de confiner peut-être le week end
confinement serré on attend toujours de
savoir ce que ça signifie en réalité
mais la vérité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
toutes ces mesures se sont avérées
inefficaces
on fait la chasse aux variants anglais
ovarian sud africain en variant
brésilien quand c'est trop tard pourquoi
n'avons nous pas fermer les frontières
quand ces variants sont arrivés à
l'époque où on savait qu'ils allaient
arriver massivement sur le territoire
par les trains par les avions etc
tous les voisins européens dorénavant
ferme les frontières prennent des
mesures drastiques par rapport aux
voyageurs qui viennent de l'étranger
parce que il n'y a pas d'autre façon
d'éviter l'arrivée de ces variants qui
viennent de pays tiers
donc on fait n'importe quoi comme
d'habitude donc on va tester pour voir
si on a effectivement beaucoup de
variants et dire ah bah ça y est ils
sont là et ils sont nombreux et donc on
va être obligé de confiner encore une
fois avec fanfare malaria
à plusieurs questions sans conflit de
sous quelle forme quand alors évidemment
un confinement léger ou très serré
combien de temps à partir de quoi et
puis la question également c'est l'école
gabriel attal ce matin a parlé d'un
allongement probable des vacances de
février à trois semaines a donc à toutes
les académies et et selon jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale selon ses propres mots ce
n'est pas acquis qui croire que
comprendre alors évidemment aujourd'hui
on a trois ministres a qui ont la parole
autoriser ces gabrielat talent le porte
parole c'est olivier ferrand pelouse à
la santé agnès pannier runes haché et
puis jean castex
pour ce qui est de jean michel blanquer
il est souvent contredits de toute façon
dans ces déclarations
soit le lendemain soit dans les 24
heures par l'exécutif par le reste du
gouvernement donc
reste à voir c'est vrai que il se bat
pour que l'école reste ouverte en disant
que ce n'est pas forcément là le lieu de
contamination
sachant que les rectorats cash le nombre
de contaminations et évite les
fermetures de classe même si vous avez
des nombres de cas assez important mais
on préfère de faire comme si tout allait
bien et les chiffres de l'école ne sont
pas les mêmes que le reste de la société
on al'impression donc
reste à voir aussi la réalité de
l'épidémie au sein des écoles
le scénario qui semble le plus probable
oui c'est au tour des vacances un jouet
avec les semaines de vacances pour
confiner les parents et les enfants en
disant c'est une période de vacances
scolaires donc après tout faisons ça et
puis vous ne partirez pas en vacances
puisque le risque c'est aussi là de voir
sur le territoire se multiplier les
foyers de contamination
tout continue en fait sans jamais
remettre en cause ces mesures
liberticides leur réalité le réel impact
sur la propagation de la maladie on
parle de quelques pourcentages de
différences par rapport aux
contaminations
tout ça parce qu'on manque de lits
toujours tout ça parce que on manque
aussi de traitement précoce on ne veut
pas essayer des traitements précoces
alors que partout ailleurs on commence à
essayer aussi de nouveaux traitements
pour voir si ça pourrait fonctionner
puisque les vaccins n'arrive pas assez
vite
compte tenu des mauvais contrats qui ont
été signés à bruxelles avec une question
parce qu'à une info qui est tombée cet
après-midi le vaste 1 le vaccin
d'astrazeneca est recommandé pour les
moins de 65 ans uniquement est ce que ça
peut mettre à mal la stratégie vaccinale
du gouvernement qui a décidé de vacciner
en premier les plus 70
les plus de 75 ans mais complètement on
vaccine avec un produit dont on a très
peu de retours y compris même le vaccin
de pfizer qui n'a pas été extrêmement
peu de données concernant les plus de 65
ans et les plus jeunes mais on le fait
donc sur les populations à risque et les
plus de 65 ans sans savoir finalement
quel est le retour est là avec
astrazeneca
c'est clair pas assez de données donc
finalement il vaut mieux éviter les plus
de 65 ans puisqu'on a vu en norvège ou
ailleurs des décades de mort très peu de
temps après la première injection sans
qu'il y ait de lien selon les autorités
entre la vaccination et la cause du
décès mais toujours est il que ce manque
de recul sur l'efficacité au delà de la
nocivité sur l'efficacité fait que on
peut se demander de l'efficacité de la
campagne de vaccination si on cible en
priorité ces publics là donc il va
falloir voir là l'idée en fait d'une
campagne vaccinale qui aurait du succès
ce serait une vaccination rapide massive
pour éviter la propagation des variants
pour éviter justement que le virus
puisse muter et continué sa course
on en est loin puisqu'on manque de doses
le l'union européenne n'ayant pas signé
des contrats qui lui permettait de
sécuriser l'approvisionnement en termes
de vaccins et puis des candidats vaccins
aussi qui ont jeté l éponge il y à
quelques quelques jours alexis poulain
là on a évoqué la prise de parole à 14h
d'olivier ferrand on a parlé de
confinement confinement également du
vaccin avec donc le vaccin d'astrazeneca
qui est donc recommandée pour les moins
de 65 ans uniquement ça vient de tomber
mais j'aimerais vous poser une question
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé hier à
l'assemblée nationale
la république en marche la majorité la
république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale qui a sifflé la fin a voté la
fin de la commission la mission
d'information sur la gestion de crise du
coc vie de 19
les oppositions à droite comme à gauche
qui sont vent debout
quel est votre interprétation de cela
mais c'est un scandale démocratique et
c'est la preuve que la vème république
est arrivé dans une caricature total de
régime ultra présidentielle tout se
passe comme si l'assemblée nationale
n'avait plus aucun point n'était plus du
tout un contre-pouvoir les oppositions
ne sont plus que décoratives et il
suffit de quelques députés de la
majorité totalement soumis est affiliée
à voulons volonté de l'exécutif pour
enterrer des commissions d'enquêté qui
sont pourtant clef mais ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est scandaleux au delà de
cette dissolution d'une commission d'
enquête c'est que tout se décide en
conseil de défense un organe qui n'a
aucune légitimité démocratique où le
président de la république décide avec
un aéropage de personnes choisies de
stratégie de liberticide de privation de
liberté pour des millions de français
sans plier de contrôle démocratique sur
pourquoi ces choix sur la réalité aussi
de l'option que des options choisies et
des choix et de l'impact sur la santé
des français et on accepte ça en fait
donc on a enterré la démocratie d'une
certaine façon mais depuis longtemps
parce que la vème république est devenu
un régime hyperprésidentiel caricatural
qui fait que l'assemblée nationale qui
devait être représentative ne l'est plus
déjà dans la façon dont les députés sont
censés représenter le peuple mais ne
l'est plus non plus dans la gestion de
l'opposition parlementaire
les oppositions n'ont plus aucun pouvoir
elles sont dépossédés alors elles
peuvent toujours s'indigner sur twitter
mais rien ne se passe
et puis se pose la question bien entendu
de l'article 68 de la destitution de ce
gouvernement mais avec une majorité
comme en marche eh bien elle cet article
est tout simplement impossible à mettre
en oeuvre
donc on est coincé avec finalement une
hyper pouvoir embastillé à l'elysée qui
décide de tout en conseil de défense
avec aucune transparence puisque le
conseil des dépenses est placé sous le
secret défense
et ça depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire sans jamais que cela soit
remis en cause alors yale sénat qui va
essayer de faire une commission denquête
mais on est loin du compte en termes de
contre-pouvoirs démocratiques
même si senna a quand même donné son feu
vert cette nuit pour un prolongement de
l'état d'urgence jusqu'au 3 mai merci
alexis poplin d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes